foreign
she says how do you respond to a job
offer that does not meet your desire
desired salary ah okay it's a good
question right
so do you go in
after they make their offer and do all
this big Grand negotiation
what do you think George yes or no I
don't think the way to go about it is
show back up and go
um yeah I need 50 to make this work or
I'm out okay all right so here you know
if the offer was 45 yeah and you thought
in your mind it was going to be 50 or
60. well it all depends on
how tight are you on on that paycheck so
if you need 50 to make ends meet and
they offer you 45 you're in a quandary
now I don't think there's this big Grand
negotiation anymore but what I do think
you can say in that situation is Hey
listen uh let's say you were in this
case making 50 previously or close to
you say look I can't do it for that I
want the job
but I just literally with my budget I
cannot make ends meet on that I
appreciate the opportunity but that's
the best you can do unfortunately I'm
not going to be able to stay now that's
not a negotiation that is you saying
very clearly uh based on real numbers
it's not a tactic it's I can't do it
then you'll see what they can do but
this idea of trying to negotiate is one
hopefully hopefully it comes up
beforehand before the job offer there's
some discussion of compensation benefits
you can't expect that in today's world
you know there there's a big push for uh
transparency and pay and put that out
ahead of time but companies that don't
want to do that for very understandable
reasons we'll come back and they'll get
around it another way so when you're in
that conversation you gotta know
what's that walk away number
if that number doesn't get to here I'm
walking away and that by the way will
come across in your communication to
where you really don't have to negotiate
and that's that's the thought George you
don't have to negotiate if you know what
your number is and what you're what
you're willing to walk from well the key
is to not put you know the HR team in a
defensive posture that's right or then
it backfires and the the the real thing
is let's do some research do you know
what the market value is based on your
skill and experience and and do you
think this company's going to be
competitive you can do that homework
ahead of time what about when they kind
of make some promises can or you know
they say well you know I know this is uh
it's not exactly what you're hoping for
but there's a big trajectory you know
within the next six months you could be
making you you kind of start to get a
little bit of that as well yes and so
what I would do if they start to say
that you're gonna go okay what's that
measurement look like
so what are the results
that I will need to produce and how will
we measure those results
because if they can't give you specific
answers to that now now it's one of
those they're just dragging you just
dangling a character and I share this on
the Ken Coleman show today this is
relevant paychecks just put out a new
study
eighty percent of people who change jobs
in 2021 and 2022
regret leaving their previous shot whoa
that's a staggering number what was the
reasoning do they have no you know right
for the number one reason it wasn't the
paycheck
it was they missed their friends from
the previous job this relationship
component it's a big shift it's like
moving to a new city yeah I mean we you
know we can't undervalue relationships
in the office so I mean you and I sit
next to each other I can't imagine ever
leaving here not having Ken Coleman I
don't know what I would do I would be
distraught if I didn't see you every
morning
and that perfectly coiffed beard of
yours and that meticulous part in the
side of your hair these are just the
surface things wow not to mention your
your character your character your
integrity your Sage advice you know all
the things George uh I love when
flattery turns to sarcasm real quick
that's the king Coleman I know and love
that's what we do